en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre la
que posiblemente es mi enzima favorita y
esa es la atp sin tasa y a partir de su
nombre podrías predecir lo que hace
sintetiza el atp probablemente lo hayas
visto antes lo vimos cuando revisamos la
respiración o lo verán cuando revisen la
respiración que está ocurriendo en la
mayoría de las células de su cuerpo
también lo ves cuando estudias la
fotosíntesis en general lo que hace es
que se asienta sobre una membrana de
fosfolípidos y a través de otros
procesos tendrás un aumento de la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno en
un lado de la membrana una concentración
de iones de hidrógeno más alta en un
lado que en el otro es posible que
tengas algunos por aquí unión de
hidrógeno es esencialmente un protón de
modo que este lado de la membrana será
más positivo por lo que habrá una fuerza
electromotriz para ir al otro lado y
también tienes una concentración más
alta así que hay un gradiente químico un
gradiente de concentración donde si
estos protones tuvieran alguna forma de
llegar
no lo harían así que hay un gradiente
electroquímico que quieren disminuir y
la atp sin tasa proporciona un canal
para esos protones pero a medida que
esos protones viajan a través de la atp
sintasa giran esta parte de la misma lo
que impulsa este eje y luego este eje
empuja estas partes de la proteína para
que se unan un a bp con un grupo fosfato
para producir atp así que aquí abajo
entrando esta parte del complejo tendrás
un grupo de adp y un grupo de fosfato y
luego esa fuerza de rotación proporciona
ese gradiente electroquímico que después
produce nuestro atp ese será el caso
tanto en la respiración que ocurre en
las mitocondrias como en la fotosíntesis
que ocurre en los cloroplastos ahora hay
algunas diferencias en las mitocondrias
los iones de hidrógeno la concentración
de estos protones se acumulan en el
espacio -entre membrana justo aquí
debido a la cadena de transporte de
electrones eso lo estudiamos en otros
vídeos
y luego los protones viajan a través de
la atp sin tasa aquí puedes ver una
pequeña versión podrías imaginar que lo
que vemos realmente grande es una
versión ampliada de esta parte de las
mitocondrias y esto por supuesto no está
escala entonces en el caso de una
mitocondria esta sería la membrana
interna justo aquí sería el espacio
-entre membrana entre la membrana
interna y externa espacio intervendrán a
y justo aquí estaría la matriz de la
mitocondria así que a medida que los
protones pasan a través son capaces de
producir atp en la matriz ahora en los
cloroplastos los protones de hidrógeno
se acumulan dentro de los si la coidh es
que son estas partes del cloroplasto ese
espacio dentro del tiroides a menudo se
llama espacio tilaco y dalt a veces
llamado el lumen esa acumulación de
protones dentro de los ti la coidh es
ocurre debido a las reacciones a la luz
la primera fase de la fotosíntesis
pero luego esos protones viajan a través
de la membrana ty la cuidad a través de
esta área que se conoce como el estroma
en los cloroplastos y producen el atp en
el estroma en seguida el atp se utiliza
en la segunda fase de la fotosíntesis
para sintetizar los carbohidratos que se
podrían ver como uno de los productos
finales de la fotosíntesis así que la
gran revelación de este vídeo es que la
atp sin tasa es increíblemente genial si
buscas en internet puedes encontrar
algunas simulaciones que muestran a la
atp sin tasa y cómo actúa como un motor
para bloquear el grupo de fosfato en el
atp para producir atp la atp sin tasa es
notablemente similar en las mitocondrias
y los cloroplastos aunque se encuentran
en diferentes partes de estos organelos
y el atp en las mitocondrias puede verse
como el producto final de la respiración
mientras que la atp producido en los
cloroplastos es un almacén intermedio de
energía que luego se utiliza para
sintetizar los carbohidratos
hasta el próximo vídeo